i'm a big fan of your work
and i wanted to jump backwards a little
bit just because i'm a huge fan of time
travel
which leads me to talking about uh peggy
sue got married
um so i just wanted to know uh
i'm a big fan of that movie can you
share what it was like working with
nick cage and coppola back then making
that film
well and coppola you know was really
interesting he he never had a leading
lady before so i don't think he knew
quite
they know to do with me you know but we
had
four weeks of rehearsal when we ever
started filming
which to me saves so much time once you
get down to
actually shooting nick was i think this
was his first
and he was you know he wanted to
do himself make sure that everybody
understood
that this was not an epic nepotistic
casting
uh so he was a little uh
a little tough at times on i thought on
cobala
you know resisting the most fascinating
thing to me
time travel wise was how to
portray you know physically a 6 16 year
old
and a 42 year old when i was neither
yeah
and it's really it's all in the body you
know it's all in what
she doesn't yet know that you have to
have to figure out and i just love those
kind of puzzles
uh your work in that film is fantastic
it's just one it's it's one of those
guilty pleasures for me when it comes on
i need to watch
um something else i wanted to ask you
about you had worked with zemeckis
on romancing the stone and i'm curious
what it was like
when he pitched you doing jessica rabbit
were you sort of like wait what
what what is this character no no
i i thought uh what he well
he did fill me in on what he was doing
i.e
um you know actually
she melding you know live action with
animation which had never really been
done before yeah
and probably will never be done again
that way because it was
it was brilliantly but you know
expensive
uh you know he kept me abreast of the
whole process
which i thought was fantastic also at
the time
i was extremely pregnant so i was going
on camera
so this was absolutely perfect for me
that's that's great what was your i mean
i think that movie is beyond brilliant
and will never be repeated because you
had characters from different studios in
one movie
what was your reaction when you finally
saw the finished film and the character
you were playing
you know the reaction to the character
uh well i loved it i loved they
loved the film i loved them i mean it
was absolutely brilliant come on you
know
uh every part of it in the process i
love um bob hoskins so
much you know i really i really miss him
um
and jessica herself well we were
we were putting the voice in because
that's one of the last steps right
you kind of leave the whole figure but
leave them the mouth and everything
vague until until i can record but
i i really had fun i would say things
like okay bob you know
she's got these huge boobs what do you
say we like throw in some
and have them bounce yeah
and he thought that was a pretty good
idea
that's great listen i could talk to you
for the entire time just about
uh that but i need to jump in um listen
i'm a big fan of kaminsky method because
listen all the performances are great
but i think it's chuck laurie's writing
which elevates this to another level uh
and i'm just curiou
because he deals with with subject
matter that no other show
really like so many shows avoid can you
sort of talk about chuck's writing and
what you love about it
oh i i absolutely agree with you that
chuck's writing is extraordinary
first of all he it's it's it's so
active friendly i mean it's there's
almost
nothing he could that he writes that i
can't
you know that isn't easy for an actor to
to understand to get into to to
personify
um the fact that he tackles a lot of the
things that he does i mean
including some of his other shows right
addiction
and um i
i just i admire him i admire him for
this
and what i when he called me to talk
about
uh doing this third season and he
described
that um the character ross would
you know would come back to work be part
of their daughter's wedding and
everything and
and she would have to interact of course
greatly with them
with sandy and that they would find
common ground that they would sort of
remember why
they were attracted to each other all
those years ago
and they get past the anger and the
bitterness
and i loved that i said my god chuck
you're writing adults
100 um uh one of the things that michael
told me last season was that chuck was
writing each episode
as you guys were filming to sort of
react to what he was seeing right in
front of
him um can you was he doing that again
this season
and what was that like no no really in
that you know we had
all five scripts sort of right at the
beginning
oh yes he would adjust he would you know
when something
took off an idea or um
suddenly became you know very powerful
very attractive he would
he dwell he would expand on that yeah
but uh no we had the material right from
the beginning and the thing that was
extraordinary to me was the fact that he
wrote
every word this was not a committee this
was not
you know a writing group with
inconsistencies and
and different voices this was just one
it was great thank you so much i really
appreciate it it's a pleasure talking
with you this morning
hope everything stays well with you
thank you very much